should I study business in school so got
a great question front of my YouTube
viewers love you guys Syed who wrote in
to say business has been one of those
things that I love going into when I was
older being an accountant or something
however art was my hobby I'm doing VTEC
art at the moment in college
and now I hate it it's not something I
want to carry on with in the future I'm
thinking to apply to business and
accounting or business degree at
university but I'm not sure if I would
find it hard with this sudden jump
please please please can you make a
video or response to let me know if it's
a good idea this is an amazing question
and one that I think a lot of people
struggle through if it's thinking about
going into university or any major life
decision you know the big decisions in
life are stressful they're scary
they require boldness and it means that
you have to act with your heart okay if
you are thinking about you know what the
study in school if you're thinking about
who to marry you're thinking about what
business to get into all the big life
decisions that you make should be with
the heart and not your head and so
thinking about this question if you hate
art okay art was your hobby you go to
university start taking art and now you
hate it what most people would do is
continue on right because it's a smart
thing to do it's a safe thing to do it's
what society tells you to do you go on
you graduate you get a job you stay in
art and you're the rest of your life in
art and you're doing something that you
hate every day of your life and it takes
a lot of guts it takes a lot of courage
to say that's not for me I don't want to
waste the rest of my life doing
something that I hate I don't want to
live for the weekends in the evenings I
want to do something important with my
life I want to feel happy about what I'm
doing and the value I'm contributing to
the world and I'm going to try something
else and to too many people hang on for
too long if it's hanging on to a
university of course hanging on to our
relationship hanging on to a business
hanging on to an idea
hanging on to anything we hang on we
hang on too long because of everything
that's been put in write all of that
time all that investment everything that
we put in we
I make it work right hanging on to that
employee we try to make it work but you
got to let go of that sunk cost right
that is a sunk cost you can't get that
time or money back you make a decision
based on what you want to do now and
where you want to go forget about
everything else and put into it if you
are not feeling this idea anymore if you
don't want to be in art anymore then
stop being an art and go to business if
that's where you want to go you have to
always follow your flow you have to do
something that gets you excited that
makes you come alive and if that's
leaving art and going to business and do
it and have the courage to jump off and
chase a life that you want to live chase
select that's worth living instead of
doing the safe thing that society tells
you to do
I want to share two quick examples for
you the first is the classic one it's a
Steve Jobs example he went to university
and he was on you know the fast track to
success and he left university dropped
out and everybody thought he was nuts
why are you dropping out and he he
dropped out of his classes he could drop
in on other classes like learning about
fonts and calligraphy and writing and
people thought he was nuts what why do
you why are you going into fonts why do
you care about handwriting it was just
something he was interested in he had no
idea how it was gonna work out he was
just interested in it and he wanted to
learn fast forward when the Macintosh
came out it was the first computer to
have beautiful fonts every other
computer had the standard boring lame
fonts and that the Mac had beautiful
fonts and that came because Steve Jobs
understood fonts because he took that
class because it wasn't afraid to drop
out of something that he hated and
dropped in and something out he loved
even though he had no idea how it was
going to work out you can look backwards
on his life and say oh that made total
sense and look look how that led to him
being a successful entrepreneur but you
can't look forward with absolute
certainty Steve Jobs didn't look at that
and say this is how I'm going to make
myself a success this is how taking a
class on fonts is going to add
you and meaning to my life he had no
idea but he did it because he was
excited and passionate about it make him
come alive and so he followed that and
you need to do the same thing business
may be your path it may not be but you
won't know until you get off our track
because art is not for you
another quick example from my past when
I was growing up my parents really
wanted me to do piano and I didn't mind
piano you know I liked the songs I like
I like understanding how the nose work
but I didn't like the music you know I
was going through the conservatory and
they have a strict regimen of the songs
and I didn't like any of the songs and I
was practicing just to practice the
songs and I didn't like any of the music
that I was playing and and it got to the
point where I wouldn't practice anymore
and I wasn't passing my exams and and I
wasn't happy right like I wasn't happy
doing what I was doing and I sat down
with my parents and both my sisters were
continuing on they were doing their
classical training and I said young I
want to find another way to do this
because I'm not enjoying this this is
not a happy moment in my life and what
we agreed on was I would continue on in
piano which I still like but I would get
to pick my own music and I remember they
bought me this this piano book of theme
songs from popular TV shows and now I
got to play the theme songs too at the
time was cheers and jeopardy and because
I'm dating myself here but but now I
liked it again you know now I had fun
now I enjoyed the music I enjoyed the
songs and even though I wasn't doing the
conservatory path anymore I was doing
something that got me excited again and
so I believe that you should be living a
life that makes you excited you should
be doing a business that gets you
excited you should be studying material
that gets you excited you should be with
a life partner that gets you excited you
should be in a city that gets you
excited right you want to be surrounded
by things that get you excited that make
you the best version of you and if
anything isn't if anything is boring and
if anything is making you wait something
like you're saying in this this question
right you hate
then cut it out from your life don't be
afraid of everything that you've lost
getting into it don't be afraid of the
uncertainty that is ahead because I can
guarantee you that by continuing to do
things that you hate you will not be
leading a happy life and by chasing
things that you love and that you're
interested in that's the path to success
believe for those of you watching like
the video you can subscribe to the
channel see more just like it if you
have advice on how you overcome painful
moments in your life or if you have
hated something how have you moved on
from that how have you gotten past it -
to realize your dreams in another area
I'd love to hear from you I'm sure save
would love to hear from you as well
leave a comment below thank you so much
for watching I'll see you soon hi every
kill English here with mermaid junkie TV
are you on evans newsletter subscription
if not you should be I read every single
one and you should too
ciao
you